in this lesson we're going to talk about
an important concept and that's knowing
how to graph parabolas so let's get
right into this lesson there's three
different forms okay of
the equation for a parabola the first
one is what they call the general form
or the standard form sometimes it's this
y equals ax squared plus bx plus c
okay and the way you would find the the
vertex of the parabola the parabola you
know bends like so this turning point is
you're going to use the formula
x equals negative b
over 2a
so here's your b value here's your a
value and that will allow you to find
the x coordinate of the vertex and then
by putting that back in you can find the
y coordinate
so let's go ahead and do this one first
and then we'll talk about the two other
forms so in this case you can see that
the opposite of b the opposite of
negative six is going to be positive six
over two times a which is three so that
comes out to six over six which is one
now if we put one back into our equation
in place of x we get let's see one
squared is one times three is three
six times one is six
plus one we get negative three plus one
which is negative two so our vertex is
going to be at one negative two so it's
going to be right there
now from here you can use a couple
different techniques one technique is
you could just
you know plot some values and usually
what i would do is pick some values on
either side of the
vertex because that vertex is going to
be
where the axis of symmetry goes through
meaning it's the same on both sides so
for example if i put zero in for x i can
see that the y intercept is one so i
know it's crossing right here and if i
reflect that over the line of symmetry i
have another point on the graph so
that's a quick way to
to get a sketch of your parabola the
other way to do it is you can focus in
on the parent function which is the y
equals ax squared part of the equation
and then what you would do is you would
make a table like an xy table and you
would just pick some values so for
example 1 squared is 1 times 3 is 3
2 squared is 4 times 3 is 12 and then
what you would do is you would plot
these points
from the vertex as if that was the
origin or the starting point so you
would go right one up 3 left one up 3
right 2 up 12 and left 2 up 12
because it's the same on both sides so
that's the way you would work with
a parabola or quadratic when it's in
this general form or standard form
however you want to say it and that
would be to memorize this formula x
equals negative b over 2a
now the second form here is what they
call the vertex form okay and then you
can see that h and k okay those are
going to be the coordinates of the
vertex so in this example you can see
that
the vertex is going to be at positive 1
positive 3. now what you want to
remember is that the one this group with
the x actually has the opposite effect
on the graph this is actually going to
shift everything positive one or right
one and this one has the same effect as
the sign so positive would go up
negative it would go down but just
remember the one group of the x has the
opposite effect so here our vertex is
going to be at 1
3 so right there there's our axis of
symmetry that goes right through that
okay that vertex and then what you can
do is if you look at this a value here
negative 2 that's going to be the same
as the a value over here okay and what
you can see is that the parent function
or the basic shape of the graph is going
to be y equals negative 2x squared and
we can make a table of values for
example one two
okay like that one squared is one times
negative two is negative two
two squared is four times negative two
is negative eight so what i would do is
i would plot those points from this
vertex right here i'm gonna go right one
down two left one down two then same
thing here i can go right two down eight
and left two down eight but you can see
that this graph is going to look
like this now again once you find that
vertex and you see that a value is
negative you know it's going to be
opening down if a was positive it would
open up like this you could just you
know pick some points just maybe like
zero is always an easy point to pick
once you find that point you just
reflect it over the line of symmetry and
you've got your graph
so that's the vertex form and then this
third form here is what they call the
intercept form
and you can see that it's basically like
a factored form you can see it's you
know factored into two binomials and
what you do here is you set each group
each factor equal to zero so you can see
that x equals one and x x equals three
so by setting these to zero and solving
that allows you to find the the
x-intercept so we know it's crossing
here at one and here at three
and then the way parabolas are
is that they're going to be symmetric so
you can find the midpoint between these
two points and that's going to be your
axis of symmetry or your line of
symmetry and then you can see that line
of symmetry is going right through x
equals 2
so by taking 2 and putting it back in to
our equation we can find the y
coordinate of the vertex so let's go
ahead and do that so 2 minus 1 is going
to be 1. 2 minus 3 is negative 1. 3
times 1 is 3 times negative 1 is
negative 3 so that means i'm going to be
down here at 2 negative 3. that's the
vertex and if you go ahead and graph
through those three points you get a
pretty good idea of what the graph looks
like so again
intercept form is like factored form you
set the factors to zero to find the x
intercepts you find the halfway point
between those two x intercepts that's
your line of symmetry once you know that
x value put it back in to find the y
value of the vertex then you've got
three points and you can get a good
graph so definitely an important concept
to understand knowing how to graph
parabolas i'll see you in the next
lesson